you never know who could be in the white
house could someone be there that would
actually take away all of our rights and
begin arresting us for who we are what
we are what we think what we read and so
I consider this to be one of those two
important pieces of legislation that
we'll put forward while all of
Washington DC is capitated by the
testimony of former FBI director James
Comey Senator Rand Paul who calls the
Trump Russia investigation a distraction
away from more important issues is busy
working on some of those issues having
to do with civil libertarian concerns on
criminal justice and surveillance this
week he's introducing a new piece of
legislation that would bar the federal
government from holding US citizens
indefinitely without a trial
we're here at the Russell Senate office
building today we're going to talk to
him about that and more we're excited
this week to be introducing a law or a
potential law legislation that would
stop the government from indefinitely
detaining someone this came about
because it really is a long history we
detained the Japanese without trial
which was a form of indefinite detention
back during World War two unfortunately
some of the courts even upheld this and
then back in the 70s we passed a will
actually back in the 50s and then again
modified in the 70s another act called
the McCarran act was passed to try to
limit the president say hey you know the
president shouldn't be allowed to detain
people like the Japanese or any other
group of people without any kind of
trial however they left a loophole they
said the president can't do it unless
Congress wants to do it and so along
comes another law a few years ago 2011
the National Defense Authorization Act
the NDAA and in it it had language that
said because we're so fearful of being
attacked by terrorists we're going to
set up this provision where we could
hold people without a trial so it's not
only not a speedy trial as a sixth
amendment says we should have it's no
trial at all basically you're just held
indefinitely now they say oh we'll give
them a habeas hearing which means sort
of a habeas corpus present the body you
got to say bring them forward and tell
them what they're accused of but as
always remind my colleagues that's the
beginning of jurisprudence that's not
the end present the body and say what
they're accused of is the start of what
you're supposed to be guaranteed
supposed to have a lawyer a day in court
a public trial a judge
the ability to confront your accusers
etc etc but in 2011 they passed this
authorization out of such great fear of
her terrorism this and oh no we just got
to be able to do this and my response to
them Fattah was do you mean an American
citizen does that mean an American
citizen could be arrested and sent to
Guantanamo Bay forever without a trial
and the response from Senator McCain was
yeah if they're dangerous and my
response to him was it sort of begs the
question who gets to decide who's
dangerous and who's not and I think most
people who looked at our legal history
and jurisprudence in general would say
you know one of the great protections
against arbitrary power is the the
ability to have to you know to have a
trial to defend yourself if you're
accused of something so I consider this
to be one of the most important issues
of individual rights probably that's
confronted us in recent times and it
didn't start with this issue I think it
started with Korematsu and maybe even a
longer history in that but I think most
people remember the Japanese internment
out of that fear and out of World War
two they passed more acts and Khazraj
can be able to well maybe we should
limited this a little bit but I think
we're at the point where we need more so
our legislation would say that neither
the President or Congress can
indefinitely detain someone without a
trial without the protections of the
Constitution and I think this is an
important thing for us to bring up we've
had a couple of votes on it about two or
three years ago we had a vote in the
Senate and it actually passed with 67
votes but if you watch Washington the
main thing to do about Washington is
it's not always what it appears it went
to the conference committee so if the
Senate has one version the house has
another version it goes to conference
committee and mysteriously it
disappeared even though we were able to
get 67 votes not to detain American
citizens to guarantee that you have a
trial it was stripped out and I'll never
forget President Obama's response he
signed the legislation you know he ran
with some sort of intent of saying he
was for civil liberties and so the
things he said when he ran I think I
admired but then he signed it and he
said well not to worry you can trust me
I will never use it
and kind of remind me of Madison's
admonition he said you know that you
can't require you can't rely on
government to be comprised of angels
basically you know you the rules the
chains of the Constitution are to you
know to make sure nobody can have so
much power and it really isn't about you
it's about the next guy or the next
woman who could be worse and more
authoritarian so I consider this to be
very very important because you never
know who's next you never know who could
be in the White House could someone be
there that would actually take away all
of a right to begin arresting us for who
we are what we are what we think what we
read and so I consider this to be one of
most important pieces of legislation
that we'll put forward and it's to
prevent indefinite detention without a
trial how would you assess the kind of
climate the political climate for that
right now I'm thinking of Theresa May a
couple of days ago said that you know we
should probably trade civil liberties to
be more safe in the wake of terrorism I
think the current administration here
shares some kind of feelings with a
Teresa maid do you feel like you're in a
better place we are in a better place to
react to terrorism this way and to be
cognizant of constitutional liberties in
2017 than we were in 2013 I think your
point is well made that the fear of
terrorism grows with each attack and
there's always people wanting to trade
their their you know their liberty for
security and so I'm not saying it's
necessarily better than it was a couple
of years ago it may be worse I do think
though that some of the things on
surveillance in general may be leaning
our way because some of the surveillance
may have been used by the previous
administration for political purposes on
the current administration that maybe
will help us in maybe trying to reform
things like FISA and 702 the backdoor
searches were all Americans records
where many Americans records can be
looked at without a warrant it may be
some benefit because of sort of the
partisan squabbling over that on this
particular issue I think there always
are people that are feeling you know
they say gosh we've got to be safe but
then when you kind of remind them you
know we are talking about something
fairly important here and you remind
them of what happened to the Japanese
whatever the Japanese is a powerful
historical story that still attaches and
you talk to people in California and the
referee
genitive from California's a very very
strong sort of pool I think the current
senator senator Feinstein I think was
old enough to actually remember some of
that as a child and do we have the
momentum to be able to do it I don't
know there is I think it's worth it's so
important that whether we can win or not
it's worth discussing it's worth trying
to bring up to get those who are
concerned with civil liberties to get
them motivated to call right get on line
write stories about it because even
though it's not been used it's an
incredibly dangerous power to allow the
government have the power to
indefinitely detain you without a file
on the surveillance thing in the current
political time did you see Lindsey
Graham's quote from I think two days ago
that he's now suddenly interested about
702 in a way that he hadn't been before
I agree and I've talked to other people
on the intelligence committees and
typically those who are on the
intelligence committees are rubber
stampers of the intelligence community
they don't really they're not at all
skeptical of power other than a few
exceptions so I think the fact that we
have Lindsey Graham now saying that you
know he might consider but you have to
get a warrant to look at information of
Americans and that's the idea that's
floating around it's a very simple one
any database that has Americans in if
you want to type in Americans name and
get a warrant and a lot of people say oh
how could we ever catch terrorists you
need to realize that even when you have
to get a warrant most warrants are
issued you know think of in DC tonight
if there's somebody that is inside their
house but their neighbor says that went
in four hours ago and someone says they
saw them they think they saw him raping
someone down the street how often do you
think a judge says no to a warrant
almost never
something judges are fairly compliant
and we kind of want them to but we still
want it to be separated such there's
someone who isn't in the pursuit of the
chase doesn't know that people involved
doesn't know the color of their skin
their race anything about them you want
an objective individual you know to make
those decisions and then 6-minute aux
about in a speedy trial right to right
to trial etc the interesting thing about
the sixth amendment and this is
something we've gotten quite involved
with as well is the story of kalief
Browder really shook me he was a young
16 year old that was accused of stealing
a knapsack and spent three years in
Rikers Island two years in solitary
confinement and I've kind of think about
I'm horrified two years in solitary
confinement with no trial
so Sixth Amendment says you get a speedy
trial we're working on that issue from a
couple of angles one is that bail and
I've started talking with Senator Harris
Kamala Harris from California about this
he had a three thousand dollar bail so a
lot of people can afford a three
thousand dollar bail in fact many people
you know will say well I'm not leaving
my kid in jail with $3,000 but if you
have no money
absolutely no money bail supposed to be
about your risk of fleeing but it's also
supposed to be individualized
you know it's different for a
billionaire than it is for somebody
that's a you know a greeter at Walmart
there's a difference in circumstances
about what is the deterrence to flight
but for him it was permanent
incarceration you know he was beaten and
all kinds of things happened to me try
to kill himself in prison and it must
have been a horrific experience you know
and then ultimately he did commit
suicide but that's a big part that's not
a speedy trial in fact you look there
ought to be any trial it ought to be
able to somebody who kept him in prison
for three years without a trial because
that's absolutely an injustice I think
there's very little of this Attorney
General of this department justice doing
anything favorable towards criminal
justice or toward civil liberties why
did I vote for him you know politics is
funny and I think a lot of people out
there because I've seen some of the
criticism they tend to sort of discount
the things that we are for and do in
legislation and think that it's that
it's much more important to you and
supported in a particular primary or how
you vote on a particular nomination as
opposed to you know the dozens and
dozens of fights that we fight every day
for you know for the individual liberty
and I think we pick and choose sort of
which fights were going to really
expend our effort on so for example I
expended a lot of effort in fact I think
I did have some impact in blocking John
Bolton and Elliott Abrams from being a
state department those I thought I had a
chance with and we did we did everything
possible on I did probably two dozen
three dozen television interviews saying
they were unacceptable and that they
didn't agree
president Trump's you know belief in
less regime change and less intervention
and we had effect if we to try to do the
same on sessions I don't think we would
have been effective I don't think it
would have worked and I think any
replacement would have been somebody
sort of equally from the same school and
so we didn't feel like we could win we
also felt like any replacement would be
from the same perspective or worse and I
think it also plays into the fact and
this is something that's hard for people
outside to see is that when you're with
people every day that you have lunch
with every day there's a certain
personal rapport and belief in the
individual that may not translate to the
you know to all their positions as well
and although the law required no reason
at all to fire an FBI director the
administration then chose to defame me
and more importantly the FBI call me
testifying right now we hear that's not
to ask you about it tight even back to
your work on civil libertarian stuff how
does this scandal his testimony affect
the climate for dealing with
surveillance issues and things like that
from your I don't know how much effects
can have on other things I think that
right now
the distraction of all things Russia and
all things Trump Russia is distracting
us from everything right now and I think
it has been overplayed I mean sounds
like and you can just imagine this if
you watch the president he's sitting
there with Khomeini saying am ia target
and he says no mr. president you're not
a target tell the public then why won't
you tell the [ __ ] you can see him
browbeating him and saying I want the
public to know because it's distracting
from my agenda and you do kind of wonder
if he really isn't a target why they
wouldn't say that publicly and you can
go into all the debate over whether or
not he is bringing undue pressure on him
but the bottom line is is as Comey
testified today nobody told me never not
to investigate this stuff anybody else
for a less volatile so why are we
selling arms to the Saudis can be
pompous next week we'll have legislation
on that as well and the legislation from
the 70s the arms Export Act allows one
senator to demand a vote
and so I will demand a vote on that
senator Murphy is my Ally on this we
have a bipartisan I think we have a
decent chance at having a very good
showing in the vote and possibly even in
winning the vote it's a vote of
disapproval and it would say to the to
the administration they can't sell the
arms unfortunately like a really bill it
has to be signed by the president so the
president could veto it still do it but
winning a battle like this would send a
huge message out there and I've been
making the point because you know we're
also talking about sanctions against
Iran but if you don't want to ran to
develop ballistic missiles maybe we
shouldn't be giving more weapons to the
Saudis because the Iranians then say
well the Saudis now have more we need
more and there really is an arms race
every time Israel gets more or Saudis
get more the Iranians want more and
vice-versa and it goes back and forth
and back and forth and also think the
Saudis are contributing to a
humanitarian disaster there's 18 million
people living at starvation levels in
Yemen and it's just horrific to read the
stories of what's going on in Yemen now
the Saudis are stoking it they use our
bombs to bomb a funeral procession about
six months ago 150 dead and 500 wounded
and we think well gosh this are going to
be an end to terrorism from that know
maybe 10,000 more people want to blow
themselves up after seeing this horrific
civilian death anyway I appreciate the
time today and those great interviews
well work on the indefinite detention
bill is just beginning a vote on the
Saudi arms deal to come as soon as next
week for reason I'm Matt Welch
you